[Musique]
mathilde endroit bonjour bienvenue ici a
look to you à montigny le bretonneux je
vous en prie bienvenue pour votre café
politique vous êtes la nouvelle
responsable du front national dans le
département yvelinois vous est également
conseillère régionale d'ile-de-france et
vous avez été candidate dans la 11e
circonscription lors des élections
législatives vous êtes rentré au front
national en 2011
c'était il n'ya pas si longtemps oui et
déjà déjà un parcours important au sein
de la formation ça tout dépend où il y
en ait fait j'ai commencé donc dans la
section jeunes du jeu au bout d'un an je
suis devenu l'adjointe à la direction du
fnj donc à la jambe je me suis je dit
j'ai été repéré par florian philippot je
suis devenu son assistante à partir du
moment où il est il a été élu des
députés européens et on bouge à perdre
un petit peu la halle la presse pour
regarder un petit peu ce qu'on disait
vous et on vous décrit plutôt comme
ambitieuse alors j'en revient justement
à votre parcours au sein du front
national est ce que cette étiquette
d'ambitieuses vous convient à dire vrai
pas vraiment parce que je pense qu'une
ambition ça se construit et peut-être
une stratégie de conquête en
l'occurrence on m'a toujours appelé on a
toujours on m'a toujours contacter pour
prendre ses places ce qui est plutôt
flatteur certes mais qui n'est pas du
tout fruit d'une réflexion stratégique
c'est une question d'opportunité
exactement parce que je travaillais
j'étais dans le privé et puis un jour
j'ai reçu un coup de téléphone qui me
disaient voilà on aimerait bien que tu
rejoindre nos équipes et j'ai accepté
alors le front national a connaît en ce
moment un petit peu de remous de
changement en tout cas il ya des
clarifications qui sont aussi dans la
ligne politique c'est des évolutions au
sein des la déformation au front
national comme comme ailleurs qu'elle
regarde néanmoins vous portez sur le
départ de françois simeoni votre
prédécesseur à la tête de cette
fédération yvelinoise je pense que
c'était surtout une petite frustration
personnelle dont nombre des responsables
en ile-de-france a été remplacé par des
profils plutôt jeune
très attaché à la figure de marine le
pen donc
donc voila et ça explique en mon avis en
grande partie son départ faire les
passes ryad de franchi oui il a plutôt
fait ce choix là effectivement il a
aussi expliqué qu'il y avait un repli
identitaire au front national qui ne lui
plaisaient pas parce que c'est le cas
aujourd'hui
à dire vrai moi j'ai pas senti de
changement parce qu'évidemment vu ma
situation professionnelle et j'ai eu des
entretiens aussi bien avec florian
qu'avec marine et
et non je pense que marine
garde toujours cette idyllique
il faut pas non plus entre guillemets ce
corner risée sur la droite voire
l'extrême droite et ne pas perdre non
plus notre fibre sociale donc je pense
que en l'occurrence être vraiment sur
l'identitaire non elle a toujours
défendu
si on parle de la question de
l'islamisme elle fait vraiment la nuance
entre islam et islamisme et les bp pas
du tout dans le même panier donc voilà
je pense qu'elle a toujours gardé cette
cette ligne a priori après diverses
discussions évidemment mais la situation
elle semble rester sur ces sur cette
ligne vous aviez mentionné florian
philippot justement peut-être parlé un
petit peu de lui et de des patriotes
vous faisiez partie de sa garde
rapprochée à florian philippon oui mais
pour la création des patriotes celle
appris par la presse comme tout le monde
donc non je n'étais pas associée à l
aventure des patriotes en tout cas c'est
en tout cas florian philippot oui parce
qu'à la vérité c'est lui qu'il est ici
et bien vous étiez vous étiez clairement
clairement proche de lui et aujourd'hui
vous lui avez voici son départ et s'être
rester et pourquoi être resté aussi au
sein du front national alors en fait
c'est moi mon objectif premier que je me
suis engagé en politique c'était
défendre mon pays je pense que le front
national est meilleur levier en fait
pour le défendre
il est de fait toujours parce que je
pense que le projet de florian
en fait n'est pas viable je pense à
terme et je regrette d'ailleurs que ça
parce que ça crée une nouvelle division
au sein de la famille des amoureux de la
france
très concrètement moi j'étais vraiment
ravi lors de l'alliance dupont aignan
marine le pen mandats présidentiels et
donc je m'aime je rêverais de plateforme
globale en fait des gens qui défendent
la france 1,6 et peu importe à dire vrai
le partiparti est un outil et donc la
création d'un nouveau parti me fait de
la peine
il fabrique un peu les cartes non c'est
probablement parce que clairement ils
ont aussi leur leur cible très
particulière en fait ils mettent en paix
de leur personnalité dans leur combat
mais c'est plus 7
je pense qu'à une certaine urgence à
jour pour notre pays et voilà univision
en plus ce n'était vraiment pas la chose
la plus opportune je pense pour nos
compatriotes
qu'est ce qui vous a motivé pour prendre
votre carte au front national en 2011
alors c'était peu de temps après mon
anniversaire j'avais 26 ans en gros
voilà le parcours aux classiques de la
trentenaire poste sciences po sciences
po dans la communication agence de com à
paris
en gros tout va bien mais quand même
cette voie là je prenais les transports
tous les jours je rentre en banlieue je
voyais un autre monde qui nous dépasse
très parisien un monde peut-être plus
enraciné mais aussi plus qui était qui
me prenais de pleine face en fait les
les menaces diverses qui était dans
notre pays sont en sécurité sur le prix
des prix des médias milliers la
bétonisation des banlieues enfin voila
c'est plein de permettre qu'ils ficus a
continué à m'ouvrir les yeux quand même
le fils d'artisan aussi donc je sais ce
que c'est qu'être la fille d'un petit
patron et autant de choses que le monde
finalement parisien de la com très
branché ne voit pas forcément et
pourtant c'est la majorité du pays et
cette majorité invisible je voulais
défendre et je me suis dit voilà ta 26
ans tout va bien dans ta vie qu'est ce
que tu as fait pour ton pays tu as été
boursière en plus tu dois rendre mois la
république à la france qu'elle t'a
offert et donc ça me semblait un peu une
évidence de m'engager d'engager le
certes mais il ya un choix qui est fait
c'est le celui du front national est ce
que ça a été un moment difficile
non parce que pour votre entourage par
exemple je n'aurais pas dit tout de
suite je l'aurais annoncé plusieurs
j'avais même cachet est en fait en fait
ils ont ce qu'ils ont surtout mal vécu
c'est peut-être que je l'aurais cachet
plus que le choix fait
moi ça me semblait assez évident parce
que je suis vraiment très attaché
à la liberté individuelle à la bande à
l'indépendance et je pense que ça doit
se retrouver à l'échelle macro donc à
l'échelle du pays et la china nation et
jeu et voilà être le serviteur zélé
d'une union européenne non élue je
trouve que c'est une insulte à la
démocratie donc déjà il était évident je
serai dans le camp souverainiste
il me restait donc du pur et unia ont
marine le pen est le but du jeu est
quand même des faire évoluer les choses
pour mon pays donc il me semblait assez
évident que ce soit marine le pen qui et
voilà qu'il ya une cohérence qui une
femme combative une courageuse et ça je
crois que je l'apprécié beaucoup pour ça
et pourtant au tout début vous étiez
plutôt proche de la gauche il y avait ce
groupe de réflexion terra nova
alors là en effet j'étais stagiaire et
parce que ça vraiment sympa j'avais un
appétit pour la chose politique et je
trouvais ça intéressant ce format un peu
co qui vient de plus en plus à la mode
finalement avec l'esprit macron de
recouper d'en haut des cerveaux pour
penser la politique
le souci est qu'on devient rapidement
techno et hors sol
il faut pas oublier que la politique
quand même ya beaucoup d'humains et
et parfois de larmes aussi parce qu'on
se rend pas compte quand on fait une
politique on bouleverse des milliers de
vie des millions de grimm et je pense
que c'est ça un peu qu'il manque un
monsieur maquereau en ce moment c'est
cette cabane ne peut pas réaliser c'est
un peu un président hors sol je pense
qu'il est moins
manger par la l'idéologique beaucoup
nombre de politiques mais il a ce côté
hors sol qui a prévenu va le pousser
progressivement vers une sorte
d'inhumanité
finalement en fait terra nova était
juste un moyen pour monsieur feu hélas
monsieur ferrand de monter en politique
par des voies non classique en fait
n'avait jamais réussir des élections et
il avait un peu peur voilà un carnet
d'adressés assez étoffé et site est
quand même intéressant on a assisté à
des groupes de discussions mais
finalement qui restent et ceux des gens
qui étaient dans un même clan et donc
fine tresser peu d'ouverture je trouvais
vous pensez que l'avenir du front
national en tout cas la figure qui doit
incarner le front national encore
aujourd'hui c'est marine le pen bas est
ce que vous en voyez d'autres au sein
des rachats d'actions devraient faire
émerger des nouveaux visages est ce que
alors je l'avenir du front national
passe par justement de nouvelles
personnalités
alors je pense qu'on est fait quand on
veut on vise à être un parti de
gouvernement on se doit d'avoir une
équipe et des lieutenants visible
identifier en revanche je pense que
marine est un très bon capitaine est là
c'est un très bon porte-voix pour moment
n'a pas émergé d'autres personnes
d'autres personnalités parce que c'est
plus que les personnes il faut vraiment
des personnalités dont certaines sont
partis bien on évoquer florian philippot
qui était une figure importante mais que
je trouve que je ne trouvais pas non
plus une file de leader et je pense
qu'on est on appartient aussi à une
famille une famille politique a besoin
de s'identifier dans un chef qui a une
posture et voilà les épaules d'un chef
et je pense que marina les épaules et
vous regardez ce qui se passe c'est
j'imagine du côté des républicains
cette recomposition au sein de la
famille politique des républicains
peut-être certains vont vous rejoindre
s'il ne se retrouve pas je pense qu'on
en ait fait que c'est toujours dans ces
moments un peu chaotique qu'on récupère
des adhérents je me souviens
montano d'appel d'urgence du sèche me
disait venez quand même les affaires
fillon copé et tout ça tellement ça le
standard exposés je pense qu'ils sont en
effet un peu perdu et puis ça nage
toujours pas à trancher sur le cas des
personnes qui veulent s'acoquiner avec
les maquereaux nist donc il va falloir
qu'il tranche rapidement parce que je
pense que l'inde et de l'indécision
n'est beaucoup de déception et une fois
que la ligne sera clair on peut imaginer
un rapprochement entre les républicains
banque nationale a été assez clair que
non ils voulaient nous laisser encore
dans le camp des pestiférés coûté 1
c'est pas grave je parlais tout à
l'heure de 2 c de ces articles qui avait
été consacrée à votre évolution
évolution politique et je lisais
notamment que les justes d'albert camus
c'était votre oeuvre littéraire
préférées alors pourquoi alors c'est une
pièce de théâtre et pourtant je vais pas
souvent théâtre mais ça m'avait frappé
c'est toujours cette question de
l'éthique en politique et
vous avez une conviction profonde il
faut la mener à bien
à fond et mais jusqu'à quel point vous
êtes capable de la mener
quand la question éthique se pose et je
pense qu'on est une époque où vous les
évolutions politiques comme
technologiques vont nous poser de plus
en plus de questions éthiques
là les premières questions éthiques qui
vont se poser c'est clairement aussi les
à ce qui est avancé par marlène schiappa
sur la pma donc 2,7
de fil en aiguille ils sont on prend le
droit français qui ne veut pas de
rupture d'égalité on sera amené à se
poser la question de la gpa qui pour moi
j'ai d'ailleurs ce genre d'usagé
d'acronymes pour cacher une réalité qui
est juste de la location d'utérus
donc voilà là aussi on est face à des
balades et des frontières éthique qui
est moral et on devrait beaucoup
s'interrogeaient on a débuté cette
émission je parlais de votre ambition
est ce que vous étiez ou non ambitieuse
en tout cas le prochain scrutin
important ce sera celui des élections
municipales
vous y travaillez déjà et qui avait été
candidate dans la 11e circonscription
des yvelines vous vous imaginez
candidate alors satisfait maintenant
comme jeu
j'ai la gestion de l'ensemble du
département je vais surtout à mon avis
axé notre stratégie municipale autour de
mantes la ville et peut rayonner autour
de cette ville en île de france par ses
rivaux que voilà que cette carte qui
montrent que voilà avoir une gestion
fine le front national au niveau
municipal ce n'est pas non plus
clairement disais c'est pas donc tous
isolés du monde
et de ses voisins donc je pense qu'on
peut vraiment articuler notre action
autour de cette ville est en fonction je
verrai 6e
il ya des besoins particuliers pour que
oui j'allais présenter une liste ou pas
ou au contraire allez partir en soutien
aux prêts des lits ce qu'on pourra
monter dans le département merci
mathilde employés responsables du front
national
[Musique]
et